هنا في مدينتي بنما مركز للغوص والانقاذ
التابع للبحريه الامريكيه يعمل على تدريب
الغواصين في المياه العميقه لدى المركز
مهمتين ازاله الحطام والذخائر غير
المنفجره في الموانئ والشواطئ والثاني وهو
الاهم تفجير انابيب النفط الاجنبيه المكان
كان مثاليا لتدريب الغواصين على مقاموا به
في سبتمبر الماضي تفجير خط انابيب نور
ستريم اثنين في سبتمبر 2022 هكذا يؤكد
تحقيق استقصائي للصحفي سيمون هرش ومن اجل
تنفيذ هذا التفجير بحث بايدن وفريقه
الترتيبات سريه لاكثر من تسعه اشهر
والاساس كانت تنفيذ دون تركي اي دليل عن
المسؤول في ديسمبر 2021 عقد مستشار الامن
القوميه الجيك سولفن اجتماعا لفريق كان قد
تم تشكيله حديثا لمناقشه الرد على غزو
الوشيك لاوكرانيا احدى ردود كانت مناقشه
خطه لتدمير نورسرين الوجوه المؤثره في هذا
الاجتماع بجانب سالب كان وزير الخارجيه
بنكن ووكيله وزاره الخارجيه فيكتوريا
نولاندو ثلاثه وجوه كانت ترى ان الخطه تفي
برغبات الرئيس بينما وصف المعارضون الامر
بانه كابوس سياسي اذا خرج للعلن وسيدخل
امريكا في الحرب ان حدثت على كل ان نفذت
الخطه وجزء منها كان اختيار خريجي مركز
الغوص في بنما لتنفيذ العمليه اختيار
مثالي ان كان المتدربون في هذا المركز
اعضاء في قياده العمليات الخاصه الامريكيه
فيجب ابلاغ الكونجرس بالعمليه السريه لكن
كونهم من القوات البحريه فهذا ساهم في
التنفيذ دون الرجوع للكونجرس وربما ما
يدعم تحقيق هرش جاء قبل الحرب باسابيع
وبعد الاجتماع الذي نشرنا اليه بشهر
وبشهرين على التوالي
في يناير وبايدن في فبراير من عام 2022
دعما وبشكل علني ودون قصد تحقيق هرش
نس
[موسيقى]